hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the air things masters uh
game three
uh between magnus carlsen and daniel
dubo magnus cross and won game one with
the white pieces then game two
incredibly complicated ended in a drop
but dubo was really pushing for a win
and he was winning
uh for uh you know a bigger part of the
game but magnus was uh
was able to grind out uh uh you know a
draw
out of that the lost position uh and now
we are in game three which is also
incredibly interesting so now let's see
what
happened again magnus with the white
pieces but this time
he doesn't go for e4 rather he opens
with knight to f3
thinking that probably he already beat
dubo twice with e for this tournament he
doesn't feel
like he'll be able to do it uh again for
the third time so knight of three we
have diretti opening
knight to f6 and now c4 uh transposing
into the english and
sorry about that uh we have e6 by black
uh and uh now comes knight to c3 uh
c5 black also fighting for central
squares and now
e3 preparing d4 we have a6
uh and here comes d4 by white we have uh
d5 by black and now comes uh c captures
on d5 so we've basically transposed into
the queen's gambit declined
uh e captures on d5 and now g3 preparing
to if you encounter this light square
bishop
knight to c6 by dubois and now bishop to
g2 magnus is now ready to castle
and here uh c4 by duba the the common
move here is bishop to e7 just
continuing development
but dove goes for c4 which um puts a
grip on white's position uh for the
moment but
will uh later be uh you know
uh magus will be able to undermine it
later on with moves like b3
yeah and so on so here uh the the most
uh
the only move ever played in this
position is knight the e5 and they was
played some
ten times in top tier games but here uh
we just have a
castles uh sorry uh castles by white and
it is
as of move nine that we have a
completely new game
so let's see what happens here dubaf
continues with bishop to b4
and now only now knight to e5 and this
is a bit of a
tricky situation you cannot go for a
trade here even though it seems like you
can double wide spawn so you're actually
going to lose material here
so for example if bishop captures on c3
b captures and knight to e4
you run into this very uh well very
unpleasant bishop to a3 now black will
not be able to castle and you're going
to suffer for the rest of the game
so you have to be careful not to do
something like this so here dubo
also castles his king to safety and now
bishop the d2
so now the knight is uh additionally
protected and
the bishop has been developed next
you're going to develop the queen
connect the rooks and so on so here
rookie 8 now there is a double attack on
the knight and here
magnus trades knight captures b captures
and only now
uh b3 uh as now the knight is
defended so b3 can be played and you are
now undermining
a white spawn black spawn chain and also
you are trying to make use of this
bishop here
so uh bishop captures with bishop
captures and now
knight the e4 putting pressure on the
bishop here and you kind of don't want
to trade this
uh you you really like your light square
bishop as an attacking
and defensive piece so you simply move
it move the bishop or play
rook to c1 which is what magnus does as
he wants to put more pressure on the c
file so a5 by do both end now comes
b captures on c4 with bishop to a6 first
spinning this pawn as the rook is on f1
and now f3 by magnus kicking away that
knight
knight captures rook captures which also
defends the e3 pawn
and only now bishop captures on c4 so
dubo grabs his pawn back and it's a very
nice position for both
black and the uh if i if i had to choose
i would say
eve black is to be even more preferred
here white has a massive center but
his king is not all that safe and the
double makes a great use of this so
first
uh carlson's rook is under attack he
plays rook to f2 gets his rook out of
harm's way and now he can shift the rook
over to the queen side if needed
uh we have queen to g5 by duboff now
with
a double attack here on the e3 pawn and
magnus defends it with
queen to c1 so also now the pawn is
defended twice and now
h5 so uh dubo pretty much tied down
carlson's pieces
um to the defense of the e3 pawn and now
he wants to play h5
h4 or bust open carlson's king's side
and try to create some sort of an attack
maybe
get a nice rook lift uh happening here
who knows
so here bishop to f1 uh magnus tries to
get rid of this bishop here and then you
know wreak havoc along the c
file so bishop captures on c1 king
captures and now
uh while you think uh maybe dubo will
try to figure out what to do with the c6
pawn there really isn't anything you can
do here so just to rocate the b8 he just
brings another
rook into the attack and really with
every game uh dubois is turning more and
more into tal so we will see where this
journey ends
so here magnus goes for the pawn there's
nothing wrong with it so he grabs it
rook captures on c6
and now comes h4 dubo continues his
attack and now uh magnus has to
figure out what to do here here magnus
plays the kind of defensive king the g2
move maybe
if he wanted to uh like maybe
maybe e4 was also an option trying to
trying to go for a nice queen trade here
because magnus is already leading
uh in their match so maybe such a move
would not be a terrible idea but i think
what magnus wanted to do was also win
this one as now he feels he's up upon so
maybe he can
uh you know finish the match right here
without even going into game four so
here magnus goes king g2
and now dubo grabs his pawn back rook
captures on e3
and now rook the c8 with check uh we
have rook captures queen captures with
check king h7 and now queen to d7 going
after this
c6 pawn so here dubo defends it and now
magnus could keep his queen in the
center or maybe even
closer to the king side but he just goes
queen to b5 he says i'm going after your
queen side pawn
as uh it looks a bit scary but if you
know you
know what you're doing there's actually
nothing going on on the king side so
here
uh duboff goes queen to f5 and it comes
with a
very nice trick uh he says okay if you
capture my a5 pawn which is
what you want to do i'm just going to
play h3 with check and after king g1
this will be game over queen b1 check
and now you can defend a few more moves
so for example rook f1 queen c2 going
after checkmate
you're gonna block the queen but now
just rookie two and that's
that's over there's nothing you can do
here captures captures is gonna be made
on the next move
so here after this queen to f5 move uh
magnus played the g4
first uh kicking the queen away he's to
capture the pawn on the next move
and now do both plays h3 with check and
again a very tricky check because if the
king captures you no longer defend your
f3 pawn twice
so you black can just capture it and
after captures and captures with check
it's just a very nice
checkmate g5 check king h5 and queen to
h3 with
checkmate uh so here after this h3 check
we basically
reach the position from the thumbnail
magnus defense with king to g3
absolute best move and now uh dubo has
to figure out what to do his queen is
under attack so he moves at queen to e4
the f pawn cannot move because because
of check here and he just wants to grab
the d4 pawn
so here magnus should think about what
to do whether to go queen to d7 help out
with the defense or maybe even queen to
f1 to help out with the defense here
maybe go after the h3 pawn
but magnus rather played queen captures
on a5 and this was
again a poison pawn thus this pawn was
uh
a no-go since dubo offered it and uh
well feel free to pause the video here
and win the game for duba
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on beating uh
world champion magnus carlsen as there
is only one move that wins this position
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's f5
and now you open up the king's position
because
any move for example a4 just runs into
queen to g for checkmate like we said
the f3
uh pawn cannot move due to this rook
being on e3
so here magnus has to play very very
carefully but
it will simply not help he captures an
f5 and now dubo recaptures queen
captures on f5
which defends the h3 pawn and now
prepares this maneuver rookie 6 to g6
which will be deadly
so here magnus has to bring the queen
back into the game queen to b5 and now
do both after some thinking about the
position goes rook to e6
magnus has to make some room for his
king for example if he try something
like f4 then just rook g6 check king f3
and queen to e4 is checkmate
so not not possible to do something like
that magnus plays the absolute best
defense he offers a rook trade with rook
to e2
but dubo sticks to his plan rook to g6
check and now magnus goes king to f2
and now a lot of moves are winning here
for black but there is one move that
ends the game on the spot so once again
uh for the last time
in this video feel free to pause the
video and win this game for duboff
uh in the in the quickest way possible
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
once again uh defeating the world
champion and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's queen
to f4 a lot of moves like i said were
possible
rook to g to check is good queen to g5
is excellent but queen to f4 just ends
the game on the spot
uh because now there really is no
defense uh whatever you do
there's queen to c1 there's queen
captures on h2 there's rook to g2 so
all of these threats you cannot parry
them all uh for example if you try
running away let's say king you want you
just get queen to c1 with checkmate king
f2 and queen to g2
with check and now queen to g1 will be
checkmate so here after
uh queen to f4 magnus tried queen to b1
to keep an eye on the back rank
but dubois played again the absolute
best uh
king to h6 and interestingly queen to b1
pins the uh rook
very nicely but duo says my position is
so good i can even waste the move uh
unpinning so he just plays king to h6
like a complete boss here and now magnus
again without without a good move queen
to d3
keeps an eye on the e3 square tries to
help out a little bit but there simply
are no squares dooba just plays queen
captures on h2 with
check king e3 and now of course the
absolute best
rook to e6 check and it was in this
position on move 38 that magnus carlsen
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
because once you move the king
uh or rather the only other legal move
is giving up the queen right away
with check so if you move the king ma uh
this is just traded queen captures uh
queen captures
rook characters king captures and now
duboff's pawn becomes a queen in this
game over
so really really an impressive game uh
out of nothing adobo creates
something uh rather a masterpiece you
and just beat magnus carlsen
with the black pieces uh you know magnus
played some very natural moves he first
grabbed
those pawns on this on the c file then
he went for the a5 pawn and
those were all uh all plausible ideas
but
uh it was just never a good time to
capture that a5 pawn and in a rapid game
everyone can make a mistake so duba
found the only way to take advantage of
it and he was able to take down magnus
which means the match is now a tie and
they have to play game four to see who
wins
the first match so very very interesting
stuff
so now once again i do hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank
andrew martin michael castagno luis
souza paul sampson and
mata granda for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
probably with the final game between the
two of them uh
and we will simply take it from there uh
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day